is a fourth grade teacher in indiana who
was just exposed for owning a satanic
temple
fourth grade teacher
teaching little nine-year-olds
is a practicing
high-level
satanist
now look i'm tolerant you know i'm a
tolerant guy and everything and we
should be tolerant no but
i think that's a little too far i think
the satanists teaching your
nine-year-old that's too much
but michael some people would say what
about freedom of religion
uh
that's not what freedom of religion
means okay
freedom
first of all freedom of religion as we
understand it is really refers to the
first amendment which says that the
federal government will not have an
established church
okay that's a very different thing from
saying satanists can teach your
nine-year-olds
right and frankly one of the reasons
that there was no state established
church at the federal level is because
there were established churches at the
state level for decades after the
constitution was ratified i don't think
the founding fathers
if they found out that their words and
documents were being used to defend uh
satanists teaching nine nine-year-olds i
don't think that they would applaud this
as some wonderful blessing of liberty
you know hold a parade for this woman uh
probably they wouldn't even argue about
it they would be too busy gathering
kindling to burn her at the stake okay
this is not the sort of thing that is
acceptable
and the school's defending her they say
we do not ask our teachers or any
employees about their religious beliefs
well yeah but if you're worshiping the
dark lord of the underworld uh that's a
little bit too far okay
religious liberty two has limits
i'll give you an example of this
if if a teacher at a at a certainly at
an elementary school but even at a
college were found to be a nazi that
teacher would be fired in two seconds
and everyone would support it
what does it mean to be a nazi it means
you hold certain political views i guess
but those views are a little deeper than
just politics right they're kind of
cultural
they're actually kind of religious their
views about the nature of man and the
nature of races and the
human dignity and worth of different
races
nazism when you really follow it down to
its
bottom has a deeply occult element to it
all of the leading nazis were
practicing some to some degree paganism
or occult rituals
it's religious because at bottom all
politics is religious okay
we have in the last few decades got into
a place where we will tolerate satanists
teaching our kids i won't i won't do
that i will not send my kid to be
instructed by satanists i will not send
my taxpayer dollars if i have any say of
it to to have satanists teach our kids
this is a wonderful use
of the political power of parents
to
shape their students education i'm so
glad you liked that clip now if you want
the whole show you've got to ring the
bell subscribe you'll get the
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts am
fm radio subscribe to the michael
knowles show leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you